[Musique]
les essentiels du Sénat
pour une ferme France compétitive
la France est l'un des seuls grands
paysagricoles au monde dont les parts de
marché recule elle est passée de
deuxième à 5e exportateur mondial en 20
ans dans un contexte marqué par la
concomitance d'une crise du pouvoir
d'achat et par une hausse des charges
des agriculteurs et des industries
agroalimentaires il est urgent de
conduire une politique de compétitivité
en agriculture défendent Laurent Duplomb
pierrelouot et Serge mériou dans leur
rapport fait au nom de la commission des
affaires économiques en premier lieu les
sénateurs dressent un constat des
nombreuses lacunes de notre politique
agricole depuis plusieurs années
celle-ci se trompe en choisissant de
promouvoir uniquement la montée en gamme
pour toutes les filières comme solution
aux difficultés rencontrées sur les
marchés internationaux
résultat la France continue de perdre en
compétitivité le risque est ni plus ni
moins un affaissement du potentiel
productif agricole français c'est notre
souveraineté alimentaire qui est ainsi
menacée à terme cette dynamique conduira
à réserver l'alimentation française à
ceux qui peuvent se le permettre
condamnant tous les autres à se nourrir
de produits importés de plus la
stratégie des pouvoirs publics en
matière d'agriculture ne porte pas une
attention suffisante aux charges des
agriculteurs déplore les sénateurs elle
ne permet pas l'amélioration de la
productivité par l'innovation et
l'investissement enfin elle ne défend
pas assez nos producteurs dans les
accords de libre-échange diagnostiquent
les auteurs du rapport
un exemple montre bien les conséquences
néfastes de toutes ces erreurs le lait
est un des produits les plus consommés
par les Français or 61% des éleveurs
laitiers n'atteignent pas le salaire
médian pour corriger le tir la
commission des affaires économiques
formule 24 propositions visant à la mise
en œuvre d'un plan compétitivité de la
ferme France à horizon 2028 après
plusieurs mois dans quête sur le terrain
les auteurs du rapport sont convaincus
qu'il faut mener une politique de
maîtrise des charges des agriculteurs
tout endopant l'attractivité des
produits français à l'extérieur la
Commission recommande ainsi d'adopter
une série de mesures fiscales permettant
de maîtriser les charges de production
elle suggère par ailleurs des
dispositions en soutien de l'innovation
dans le domaine environnemental
les rapporteurs plaident aussi pour une
révision de la politique
d'accompagnement à l'exportation ainsi
que pour un renforcement des protections
contre la concurrence déloyale
pour en savoir plus consultez la
synthèse du rapport
[Musique]